hello everyone so this video was a part
of the GE Howcast ecomagination youtube
video challenge the results are in for
the most requested things to do to go
green I read through all of your
comments and these same suggestions kept
coming up over and over again
coming in at number 3 turn the water off
while you're brushing your teeth and at
number 2 unplug any electronics that
you're not currently using and the
number one most requested thing to do
aside from painting myself green and
running around the street which I was
not about to do sorry
was to ride a bike instead of driving
your car now I normally pretty much walk
everywhere that I can so I thought that
I would give that bike thing a shot
most requested thing for me to do to go
green it was to ride bicycle and to
carpool what are we doing
thank you guys so much for all of your
awesome comments I had so much fun
making this video now don't forget to
check out the link below to see all the
other wonderful videos that other
youtubers have created for this
ecomagination youtube video challenge
and don't forget tag your green and I
will see you guys in the next video I
was gonna try to do something cool there
but it didn't happen